obviously a lot of people talking about
uh the book uh
white fragility which i believe was
written about a year or two ago but
you know immediately became uh this
th this uh very sought after book uh
after the killing of george floyd and
and people talking about well
discussing what's in there what i found
was really interesting
was in that book there's
addressing this idea that
um white people have so much
fear and sensitivity about race that
we're afraid to make a mistake
and then you think about it you think
well a faux pas is a small price to pay
for
trying to engage meaning if the price
that i'm going to have to pay
to educate myself and to
grow and evolve is to be embarrassed
a bunch of times that is
less than the size of an atom compared
to the
himalayan mountains which are hundreds
of years of racial discrimination
so get over it i think i encourage
people to think of well what's the worst
thing that can happen
right if you if you put on a black lives
matter t-shirt or you put a sign in your
window
or you take the step to bring something
up to a family member and
that's like you know might might be
uncomfortable or awkward or even really
contentious
what's the worst thing that can happen
and what are you willing to risk for
something that you believe
um you know and i think that what i want
to encourage people to do
is if you know is to get clear on your
beliefs if you believe
uh that we have a history of systemic
racism in this country
if you believe that black and brown
people are disproportionately mistreated
by police uh if you believe these things
if you believe that black lives matter
then you know what are you willing to
risk to talk about that and to share
that message with people in your
community
in some ways very simple and yet clearly
we talk about there's the paralysis and
fear
that we see in this country about people
worried to make a mistake and then the
flip side what i want to ask you about
is defensiveness it's a very simple
thing to go i don't know
maybe i did maybe i did make a mistake
maybe i was biased maybe maybe
how could i not be biased let's talk
about it
it's such a simple thing to do but but
people put up this defensive wall
and it's that defensiveness i think is
the hardest thing to get over
it is and you know to what i like to you
know i kind of like to turn it around
and say like
what exactly are you defending no can
you get that upset
um because we've had this conversation
and it's that's the thing it's not just
about getting accused of doing something
that is seen as racist you know
people will be furious that you and i
are actually having this conversation
um you know so for those people it's
like what what are you so upset about
how is this harming you what exactly are
you defending
um are you just defending white
supremacy are you defending
um you know uh that that position um
yeah it's it's the defensiveness is huge
and i i you know
i really appreciate um you know you i
appreciate you having me on and i
appreciate you being willing to have
this conversation
after the fact right because i think
that in all these conversations that we
have
about what white people can be doing and
be better and all this stuff i think
accountability and
follow-up is a huge part of it right so
we can have these conversations in the
weeks after these horrific things happen
but then we kind of go back to normal
right yeah i
i was going to show um like i don't have
it as a
but i was going to hold up my phone and
say we are very much
uh a society that's like what are we
talking about now
so uh right now it's trump's getting
impeached
and that's all anybody wants to talk
about and then
we move on and then it's covid and then
we move on and then george floyd
is killed and uh
everybody says this is now what we're
going to talk about and you think this
is fantastic and
it's not that people are consciously
saying dismissing it as an issue
but then covid resurges and we move on
and then
that is i think the issue is so much
good
or dialogue so much good dialogue and so
much raw emotion was vented
in the last two months
that you think let's
a sort of a path has been opened i don't
think we've ever seen sustained
anger and concern like that in my
lifetime um
i'm 28. yeah you're a lot younger than
me
so yeah yeah i just it's sun damage um
but we haven't seen this
and yeah this is a an opportunity to
keep the path open and keep exploring
so you're right i mean i i i do think
it's essential to
not say well check we did racism
yeah right we pulled down a bunch of
statues and
um i think we're good let's move on
because
we haven't moved on you know the brianna
taylor's killers are still
uh still walking free and um there's
still people in
in louisville who've been protesting
every single day for months getting
arrested and
and not relenting and so you know i
think sometimes what happens too
is that for especially with you know
white people if it's not immediately in
your feed
and in your immediate in front of your
face in your feed
then you think oh it's not it doesn't
exist anymore so i think uh you know
the the level at which we saw the point
of protest happening
all over all the time constantly um
that's still happening in a lot of
places um it just might not be showing
up in your feet so
um you know be sure to be diversifying
your feet and paying attention to it
because it's all still happening but i
think you're right that there is a path
that's open and
this is a time for people to really be
thinking critically about
how do you stay on that path now it
doesn't mean that everything you do now
has to be completely
uh you know all about racial justice
unless that's the work that you really
want to be doing
i've been watching everybody you've had
on and you've had great people on that i
love
and you've had some incredible
conversations with your black guests
that you've had on
well what happens when will ferrell
comes on
i love will you know what does it look
like when in addition to his new movie
you also say hey like how are you
feeling about you know
the changes in society what how did
how'd the killing of george floyd affect
you
you know will or pablo or whatever
person's on
um and that's where there's like a real
that's unexpected and i think that's
where the me
the needle starts to get moved you know
and it's goes back to that idea about
discomfort like that's why people do not
expect
to be asked about race because we don't
see ourselves as part of race we often
see racism as something that happens
to other people who do not look like us
and
we didn't do it right but we are
actually totally complicit and
diplomacy uh impacts us all negatively
so no i i think that's a really good
point
i think it's what's interesting about it
is the concept that
when you're when you're talking to
people and this is something
i honestly don't know the answer but
where i'm talking to people in
entertainment about their project
is then figuring out a way to do it
which
doesn't look like a gotcha doesn't look
like
um i've you know uh
and also asking them they may have very
visceral strong feelings about it and
they may not be prepared to talk about
that
so there needs to be a way to figure out
how can i
how can that be part of the conversation
ongoing
without it looking like i'm trying to
make people uncomfortable
do you know what i mean yeah but you
always are kind of making people
uncomfortable
you know that's just my appearance
[Laughter]
i can't do anything about that no i
can't believe we've been having to look
at this for so long
the thin lips and the eyes and uh yeah
no but i i agree that um
that there needs to be many different
ways
like one of the approaches that i've
wanted to take
is how can i not even so much as a
person with whatever kind of platform i
have
i'm always wary of my platform because i
think
my and i think i should be wary of my
platform because i
i'm not even comfortable with the word i
i feel like i'm someone who
has some ability at being silly and that
has
brought me into people's homes for a
long period of time
and so i'm wary of leaning against it
like the most important thing to me
has been how do i personally how do i
evolve how do i change the culture
that's
my ecosystem around me how can i improve
it how can i make
changes that and and sort of lead by
example does that make sense
it makes perfect sense you know taking
inventory of
of who's working for you you know by the
way everybody you work with that i've
interacted with
so far has been the nicest people ever
so good job
love them all um i've i've tried to fire
them but they have legal protections
which infuriates me you know labor
movement
but i really want what i really want is
a staff of [ __ ] but i legally don't
know how to
how to pull it off i don't know how to
do it um
i'm sure you can find a lawyer who can
help you figure that one out um no
i think that you know like whether it's
looking around at who are you employing
who are you working with who you're
hiring what does your writing room look
like
you know who are you bringing in what
does it like to be potential about that
you know but um but i wanted to say to
the idea of how do you bring up those
conversations in ways that don't feel
like i gotcha
you know again i think black
entertainers have been
there that's what they do i watched the
wonderful nicole buyer when you had her
on she's hilarious
and she talked both about the pain and
the challenge of this moment
and she also talked about her amazing
new book you know
what's uh uh great
is when i i love so many people are we
have a writer on our staff lori
kilmartin who's very good
at talking about she just lost her
mother to covid
and she was able to take that pain and
and
and braid it intertw entwine it with
humor in this way that was like a
razor's edge
and i think uh chris redd from starnet
live was
on and he was um you know
he's he can be so funny where he's
walking the razor's edge of
he he can bring up being afraid of
hearing someone be racist when he's
playing
a video game and they don't know who he
is and maybe someone's gonna you know
shout out the n-word uh and and not know
that he's
there but he was very funny talking
about that in a way that
it's such a powerful weapon to be funny
and bring up the biggest nuclear bomb
issue
in american history for the last 250
years
and somehow combine the two those i mean
it's
so many entertainers are so good at
doing that
um and i think that's a very powerful
tool as well
and i think that's you know that's what
i always loved about kamau and his work
is how he does you know yeah
comedy is an incredibly powerful tool
and uh you can you know you can do
so much you can go places and have
conversations that people ordinarily
would be too afraid to go to